we've been covering is about standing
soldiers here a biographic slightly
today's protagonist is no exception and
will probably rank among the very top
because of his determination courage
tactical competence and resilience this
is the extraordinary story of Master
Sergeant Rowell Roy Benavidez the
Lazarus soldier and of his three lives
this outstanding individual never
surrendered in the face of adversity
from childhood to military life those
who know his story mostly remember him
for a six-hour cavalry during which to
great personal sacrifice he held at bay
an entire battalion of North Vietnamese
infantry to save eight wounded comrades
but how did he get there
and what happened afterwards well let's
begin with his difficult childhood in
Texas
[Music]
Raul Perez Benavidez also known as Roy
was born in Cuero Texas on the 5th of
August 1935 Roy was born in a family of
Mexican Americans established in DeWitt
County Texas
Roy's father Salvador worked as a
sharecropper he was married to Teresa
Perez an American Yaqui Indian the
childhood of Roy it was not a happy one
on the 7th of November 1938 Salvador
died of tuberculosis aged only 27 Roy
was only three four years later
Teresa also died again from tuberculosis
Ryder's younger brother Roger they were
sent to live with their uncle Nicholas
aunt Alejandra and eight cousins at our
Campo Texas
Roy dropped out of school in the seventh
grade his help was needed to support the
family so he had to forego in education
to work in the fields picking sugar
beets in cotton Texas in the early 50s
did not offer many prospects to a farm
laborer who was also a school dropout
Roy films a chance for a career and a
better future in the military in 1952 at
the age of 17 Roy enlisted in the Texas
National Guard
two years later Roy joins the US Army as
private Benavidez receiving his infantry
training at Fort Ord California
Benavidez his service duties soon took
him out of the country first South Korea
then to Germany upon his return to the
States in 1959 he reunited with Hillary
Akoya childhood sweetheart and the two
married on the 7th of June they went on
to have three children
Knowle Yvette and Denise by now army
life for Benavides was not only a means
to provide for his family
it was the life pure and simple a life
that he enjoyed he was very good at he
expanded his training and in 1959 he
attended the military police school in
Fort Gordon Georgia Benavidez racked up
qualifications becoming also a
paratrooper and he was assigned to the
82nd Airborne Division by 1965 Benavidez
was on a tour of duty in Vietnam acting
as a military adviser to the South
Vietnamese army one day he was on a solo
patrol mission which according to some
accounts was part of a covert operation
its aim was to gather intelligence of
possible Vietcong infiltration within
the South Vietnamese Army that was a
fateful day Benavidez stepped on a
landmine and it left him badly wounded
with serious bone and cartilage damage
to his spine he was immediately
evacuated to Brook Hospital in San
Antonio
than to Fort Sam Houston the Army
doctors gave him a devastating diagnosis
he would never walk again
meaning they had to discharge him from
the military they might as well have
thrown him on top of another mind Tim
and his family active service meant
making a living it meant life itself a
discharge it was the equivalent of death
what our Benavidez did in the following
weeks would have been described as a
miracle in another place of time
ignoring medical advice Benavidez went
on a recovery program of his own in
secret every night he slipped from his
bed and onto the floor using his elbows
and chin he dragged his body to the
nearest wall then in a pain so
excruciating that it left him in tears
or I would set himself up against the
wall and propped himself into a standing
position he then spent the night just
trying to wheel his toes right foot left
foot and then again every single night
he was determined to walk and return to
Vietnam he felt a sense of duty towards
his fellow comrades many of whom came
back from their tours of duty with limbs
missing truly unable to walk again
night after night Benavidez continued
with his ritual sometimes he was caught
by the nurses given some sleeping bills
and put back to bed but most nights he
managed to keep his appointment with the
wall and he recovered most of his
mobility often 9 months a doctor showed
up with discharge papers Benavidez told
him to hold on and watch what he was
able to do Roy jumped out of the bed
stood in front of the doctor almost
fainting because of his back pain the
doctor was impressed and told him
Benavidez if you walk out of this room I
will tear for papers and Benavidez he
walked out of the room he walked out of
a hospital like simple as ER as he had
walked out of his grave and into the
start of his second life
[Music]
after leaving the hospital Roy Benavidez
spent months in grueling rehabilitation
and training at Fort Bragg North
Carolina this is the main training
center for the US Army Special Forces
also known as the Green Berets the ends
at Fort Bragg with a limp soon he was
running five to ten miles and dropping
1,500 push-ups every single day while
perfecting his parachuting skills in
January of 1968 Staff Sergeant Roy
Benavidez was back in Vietnam he had
been assigned to detachments b56 5th
Special Forces Airborne group with the
codename tango Mike Mike in NATO radio
code these simply indicate the letters T
mm apparently Benavidez himself had
selected these letters an acronym that
stood for that mean
Mexican it would only take a couple of
months before the mean Mexican launched
into the military action that would
eventually earn him the Medal of Honor
he would later describe what happened as
six hours in hell on the 2nd of May 1968
Benavides was at the Loc Ninh Green
Beret outpost near the Cambodian border
attending Mass at 1:30 p.m. the radio
came alive with a panicked request for
help it came from a squad of 12 men a
reconnaissance team that had been
dropped by helicopter west of Loc Ninh
and they were tasked with collecting
intelligence on enemy activity the team
included 9 Vietnamese Montaigne or
mountain men these are an ethnic group
which had signed with the US and South
Vietnam against the communist north the
team also included three US servicemen
sergeant first class Leroy right
Staff Sergeant Lloyd Frenchie masu and
specialist for Brian O'Conner the patrol
had stumbled upon an entire infantry
battalion of the North Vietnam People's
Army
the NVA numbering up to a thousand men
they'd been quickly surrounded three
helicopters already attempted to extract
them but intense enemy fire prevented
them from landing Benavidez was
listening with increased concern to the
radio he knew the men involved and
Sergeant Leroy Wright was a good friend
back in april Benavidez and another
comrade were on an intelligence mission
deep behind enemy lines when the other
soldier had been wounded a helicopter
had come to extract them unable to land
the chopper had lowered to two ropes for
the men to hook onto during the fly to
the two ropes were badly tangled and
were about to break sergeant Wright who
had been on the helicopter lowered
himself with another rope disentangled
the knot and then sang over to Benavidez
his life tangu Mike Mike took a snap
decision he would help Leroy and the
others they
make it back alive as a fourth rescue
helicopter was being readied for another
attempt Benavidez jumped on board armed
with only a knife and his medical kit
the chopper reached the site of the
engagements the reconnaissance team was
surrounded by the NVA soldiers enemy
fire prevented an immediate landing so
the aircraft have to move 75 yards away
from the rice and his men Benavidez
jumped to the grounds and ran towards
the men when a Vietnamese bullet in his
right leg he fell that was immediately
up again and running next who was the
full blast of a grenades that slammed
him to the ground his face covered in
shrapnel but this was still not enough
to stop him he got up again and he
reached the patrol that had split out
into two groups four of the more guards
lay dead and he took one of their AKA
assault rifles and then focused on
treating the wounded luckily he had
brought along plenty of morphine for
those who were screaming in pain the
only way to stop the overwhelming NVA
battalion was to call in an airstrike
Benavidez did serve iRadio
also requesting another helicopter
another bullet at this point pierced his
right fine thankfully the oncoming
chopper succeeded in landing and
Benavidez dragged the dead and the
wounded on board the NVA soldiers
intensified their fire against the
aircraft which prompted another act of
sacrifice from Benavidez rather than
jumping aboard he ordered the pilot to
fly to the second group while he
provided suppressive fire from the
grounds Benavidez spotted lea right he
was on the grounds not far from the
second group but he was dead
instinctively Benavidez removed from
Wright's body all documents containing
their units radio codes and call signs
these codes would have made useful
intelligence and the hands of the NVA it
was at this point that everything went
wrong even more wrong first bullet hit
him in the stomach the third shot he had
endured then a grenade exploded behind
his back with more shrapnel piercing as
flash we're still the pilots was shot
dead and the helicopter crashed
Benavidez limped back to the wreckage
and was able to extract his wounded
comrades
their only path to safety was to call in
another airstrike and get another
Tropper but first he quickly set up a
defense perimeter all the while
encouraging directing and caring for the
wounded men throughout the fighting
Benavidez a devout Catholic made the
sign of the Cross so many times that his
arms were going like an airplane
propeller
jetson
gunshots finally returned to harass the
enemy by this time Benavides was almost
rendered blind from all of the blood in
his eyes so he had to rely on his sense
of hearing to direct the airstrikes the
new rescue chopper it finally landed
Benavides carried his comrades to the
safety of the helicopter one at a time
during the second trip while he was
shoving french riba so aboard an NVA
soldier closed up to him and clubbed him
on the jaw with a bud of his rifle
Benavidez fell then got up just in time
to stop the soldiers Burnett with his
bare right hand the Vietnamese man
managed to slash his left forearm before
Benavidez fought back with his bowie
knife stabbing him multiple times after
having secured Frenchy on board
Benavidez spotted two more NVA troops
advancing shooting the chopper he grabs
an ak-47 and fired them silencing good
his mission was not finished though with
the little remaining strength in his
body Benavidez rush back to the defense
perimeter to rescue the last mantener
and all the classified documents
Benavidez at this point was in critical
condition he was bleeding from numerous
wounds and he was blinded by the blood
hemorrhaging in his eyes he also had a
dislocated jaw his intestines were
exposed because of the gunshot in his
abdomen and he was having to hold them
in with his hands but everybody else was
safe so he allowed himself to be pulled
into the chopper on route 2 Lachman
Benavidez closed his eyes when the
chopper landed at the field hospital the
medics tended to the wounded immediately
and collected the bodies of the dead
soldiers one at a time they were placed
in body bags
amongst them with Staff Sergeant Raoul
Roy Benavidez codename tango Mike Mike
Jarry Cottingham friends recognized
Roy's body and screams that's Benavides
get a doc when the doctor arrived he
placed her hands on Roy's chance to
check for a heartbeat he shook his head
saying there's nothing I can do for him
the doctor proceeded to zip up the body
back half of Sergeant Benavidez body had
already been swallowed by the sinister
black bag then the doctor closing the
zipper had the surprise of his life the
body of Benavidez spat at him the
surprise doctor reversed Roy's condition
from dead - he won't make it but we'll
try Roy had not surrendered he was in
critical condition having suffered more
than 30 wounds he cannot talk because of
the broken jaw and his eyes had been
sealed shut
by congealed blood the Benavidez was
still alive unable to communicate
otherwise he spat to attract the
doctor's attention and it worked
staff sergeant Benavidez had saved the
lives of eight men - great personal
sacrifice he spent almost a year in
hospitals to recover from his injuries
he had seven major gunshot wounds one of
them having barely missed his heart both
arms had been slashed by a bayonet
Benavidez a trap not in his head
scalp shoulder buttocks feet and legs
his right lung was also destroyed he had
injuries to his mouth and the back of
his head from being clubbed with a rifle
but the Medal of Honor citation would
later acknowledged that his fearless
personal leadership tenacious devotion
to duty and extremely valorous actions
in the face of overwhelming odds were in
keeping with the highest traditions of
the military service and reflect the
utmost credit on him and the United
States Army so how did he do it how did
Benavidez manage to accomplish these
actions which just short of miraculous
and how do you are the soldiers and
individuals in high-risk situations
accomplish feats that appear superhuman
Benavides later claimed that he was
simply doing his duty and to survive six
hours in hell he clearly had a strong
sense of that he was motivated to
protect his friends and to save the
classified documents losing the
intelligence may have endangered further
lives in addition to a strong sense of
purpose Roy Benavidez was no fresh
recruit he was an experienced sergeant
of the Green Berets the Special Forces
of the
Saamy in the 1960s their typical
training included parachuting
marksmanship close quarter combat and
extensive medical fast a drills which
made virtually every Green Beret a
trained paramedic this was a skill
Benavidez good use and yet what is
really astounding is how he Nunn
Institute simply stay standing up after
six hours of exhausting non-stop action
and a total of 36 wounds which must have
caused excruciating pain he did
administer morphine to his comrades but
never to himself otherwise he would not
have found the lucidity necessary to
plan on-the-spot the defense perimeter
to retrieve the Intel to fight back
against the NVA soldiers the answer
though it might lie in another drug one
created by the human body adrenaline the
word adrenaline today is used almost as
an abstract term to indicate an
extremely excitable and alert state of
being in practical terms adrenaline is a
hormone and a neurotransmitter produced
in the adrenal glands adrenaline is
released into the bloodstream and
conveys nerve impulses to various organs
its effects are to prepare the body for
the fight-or-flight response in times of
extreme stress
it sets the body up for vigorous and
sudden action the key effects of the
onset of adrenaline include increased
heart rate and blood pressure expansion
of the air passages and redistribution
of blood to the muscles this explains
the increased strength speed stamina and
pain threshold experienced by
individuals who like Benavidez find
themselves in a life-and-death scenario
the effects are not limited just to the
body though this hormone also maximizes
blood glucose levels increasing its
concentrations primarily in the brain
this is like providing a sudden boost of
fuel to one's cognitive function which
enabled Benavidez to sustain six hours
of intense fighting but most of all six
hours of brilliant tactical leadership
and medical and evacuation work and what
was the reward for all of these actions
well I would be the Medal of Honor Staff
Sgt Vitas was absolutely worthy of
receiving the highest u.s. army
accolades the Congressional Medal of
Honor but this did not happen
immediately as he was recovering from
his wounds in 1968 he was awarded the
Distinguished Service Cross also
prestigious but not as much as the Medal
but the process to obtain the Cross it
was shorter and his commanding officer
was not sure if the
Vedas would survive when Roy Benavidez
after one year in hospital returned to
active service his new commander Colonel
Ralph Drake undertook a campaign to
ensure that he received the Medal of
Honor but there were two problems at
this stage first
there wasn't any witness from the US
military that could confirm the full
extent of his actions second according
to Benavidez as children the process
took so long
because the action had taken place in
cambodian territory the government could
not admit taking part in such
engagements in a country that was not
involved in the Vietnam War at least
officially finally in 1980 your witness
emerged it was Brian O'Connor the
specialist who had survived the battle
hidden and living in Fiji but during a
trip to Australia he heard about the
Benavidez case picanha gladly
volunteered to write a full report on
Roy's actions and then flew to
Washington to presented to the
government a blast On February the 24th
1981 President Reagan presented the
Medal of Honor to Roy Benavidez he was
the last of the Vietnam era military to
be presented with a medal from that war
during the past decade Benavidez had
rose to the rank of master sergeants and
has sought to advance his education
attaining his GED and college degree
during all this time he suffered chronic
pain from his injuries in 1976 Roy
Benavidez decided it was time to retire
from the Army and was granted some
well-deserved disability payments on top
of his pension when President Reagan had
presented Roy Benavidez with the Medal
of Honor
he had asked the former sergeant to
speak to young people about the
importance of pursuing education Roy did
just that as a retired sergeant he spent
time visiting schools to stress the need
for the education that he never had as a
child he also became a prolific
motivational speaker delivering talks
about his extraordinary life experiences
to audiences of students military
personnel and businesses but his days of
fighting they weren't quite done shortly
before Memorial Day 1983 Roy Benavidez
released statements to warn that the
Social Security Administration planned
to cut off disability payments to him
and other Vietnam War veterans the
federal cost-cutting plan had terminated
the disability assistance for 350,000
people over the preceding two years it
was now also impacting than if he does
the retired sergeant had developed a
friendship with Ronald Reagan after
being decorated and he was not about to
shy away
from leveraging this friendship he said
I don't like to use my Medal of Honor
for political purposes or personal gain
but if they can do this to me what will
they do to all the others ten days after
Roy statements to the press the
Secretary of Health and Human Services
Margaret Ann Hakala said the disability
reviews would become more humane and
compassionate Benavidez continued his
campaign he testified to the House
Select Committee on Aging that the same
administration that had given him a
medal was now withdrawing his benefits
which were part of his rights as a
wounded veteran he then proceeded to
file an appeal to an administrative law
court in 1983 the court overturns the
initial decision and sanctions that
Benavidez continued receiving payments
it was an important precedence that
would help many more veterans from then
on Benavidez continued as engagements as
a speaker in support of education and
overcoming impossible odds by all
accounts he was a loving father and
grandfather he didn't force quite a
rigorous discipline at home based on his
Catholic faith and he must have appeared
intimidating to his daughter's
boyfriends but as his daughter described
him he was the biggest teddy bear in
life in October of 1998 after many years
of struggles against diabetes Benavidez
had his right leg amputated due to
complications from the disease he never
recovered fully and on the 29th of
November rage 63 right Benavidez
succumbed to respiratory failure at an
Army Hospital in San Antonio Texas over
the years fellow Texans paid tribute to
Benavides several schools a National
Guard Armory Army Reserve center and
even a ship of the Navy have been named
after him
Roy Benavidez his life was one of
struggle sacrifice and rebirth not once
but twice and yes he did not regard
himself as someone special
the real heroes are the ones who gave
their lives for their country I don't
like to be called a hero I just did what
I was trained to do so I really hope you
found that video interesting if you did
please do hit that thumbs up button
below and don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos four times a week I'll
say at that notification bell just the
way YouTube works if you really want to
get like a notification about when we
put out a new video you need to do that
and as always I'll see you next
[Music]